شخصيه الرئيس التونسي الاسبق زين العابدين
بن علي ما ابرز الصفات التي طبعت او صبغت
هذه الشخصيات
ومنظم اداريه طبعا التكوين العسكري له
وانسان من ضبط الوقت
في الزمن يعني كم سنه مجلس الوزراء يبدا
الساعه 10:00 ساعه 10 ايام الساعه 12:00
لا يتاخر يعني حتى المواعيد مع الاستقبال
الناس الى اخره هذا حاجه مهمه جدا كانت
كثيره
يعني اللي يحب طلع على الملفات اي ساعه
كان يبلش دوامه بكري يعني كان يسبقون
جميعا الى مكتبه شو بكرا يعني الصبح 6:30
واذا كان عنده ارتباطات في المساء يعني
يعملها ولكن
الدوام الطويل هو كان الشيء المفضل عنده
يعني في سنوات الاخيره احيانا يخرج
الفاتوره شويه ويرجع وهيرجعش يتكلم عندوش
عنده لقاءات خاصه الى اخره
همم كان رجل مثل اخلاق يعني
الاستماع
بطبيعه الحال همم
الوزير الاول الذي هو همم
الحكومه
السابقين الذين خاصه الذين
يعني كل من نسجل معهم يقول كان هو متهم
بالديكتاتوريه ولكن كل من عمل معه يقول لا
كان يستمع يعني على زين العابدين بن علي
وغيره من الرؤساء السابقين يعني اشرح لي
يعني انه انا مستغرب شخصيا يعني مستغرب
يعني
زين العابدين بن علي يعني لم تكن فيه صفات
همم الديكتاتور الديكتاتور انا قريت عاد
دكتوريين همم في التاريخ الكل من نيرون
اللي كان امبراطور روما حتى همم
جدد في القرن العشرين يعني له مقارنه هو
كان رجل منظم همم صلب منضبط الى اخره
يستمع ولكن عندما يكون عنده قرار او وجهه
نظر مختلفه يحاول ان يمررها
في نهايه العمليه
التي
قائم ولكن لم تكن دوله توصف بانها دوله
بوليسيه امنيه دوله قامعيه وهو يراسها واي
دوله ليست فما ما فيهاش بوليس وما فيهاش
قائمه حتى الدولتين
هذه لا يحكموا اهل البوليس
ما الذي كان يحكمها كان يحكمها رئيسها
ونظامها بالعدل والقانون بالعدل هنالك
تجوزت حصلته هناك
قبائل اتحدث عن لاننا ثقه في العداله وهذا
شان تونس
او قضايا بالمئات والالاف من القضايا
التعذيب ضد الاسلام من قضايا قتل من
القضاء الى ما هنالك يعني كل ما وقع من
قضايا هو رهن القضاء اليوم
وكل الدول تحصل فيها تجاوزات وحتى الان ثم
تزوجت